what is a man with new test and how is
it calculated that's what we will
discuss in this video let's start with
the first question what is a man with
new test a man with the utest tests
whether there is a difference between
two independent samples an example is
there a difference between the reaction
time of women and men but the t-test for
independent samples does the same it
also tests whether there is a difference
between two independent samples that's
right the manual EU test is the
non-parametric counterpart to the t-test
for independent samples but there's an
important difference between the two
tests the t-test for independent samples
tests whether there is a mean difference
for both samples the mean value is
calculated and it is tested whether
these mean values differ significantly
the man with new test on the other hand
checks whether there is a rank sum
difference how do we calculate the rank
sum for this purpose we sort all persons
from the smallest to the largest value
this person has the smallest value so
gets rank 1. this person has the second
smallest value so gets Rank 2 and this
person has the third smallest value and
so on and so forth now we have assigned
a rank to each person then we can simply
add up the ranks of the first group and
the second group in the first group we
get a rank of 42 and in the second group
a rank of 36. now we can investigate
whether there is a significant
difference between these rank sums but
more on that later the advantage of
taking the rank sums rather than the
difference it means is that the data
need not to be normally attributed so in
contrast to the t-test the data in the
man with new test do not have to be
normally distributed what are the
hypotheses of the man with new test the
null hypothesis is in the two samples
the rank sums do not differ
significantly the alternative hypothesis
is in the two samples the rank sums do
differ significantly now let's go
through everything with an example first
we calculate the example with data Tab
and then we see if we can get the same
results by hand if you like you can load
the sample data set to follow the
example you can find the link in the
video description we simply click on
datatap.net and open the statistics
calculator I've already loaded the data
from the link here you can also copy
your own data into this table then all
you have to do is click on the
hypothesis test Tab and then and simply
select the desired variables we measure
the reaction time of a group of men and
women and want to know if there is a
difference in reaction time so we click
on response time and gender we don't
want to calculate a t-test for
independent samples but a man Whitney U
test so let's just click on
non-parametric test here we see the
results of the man Whitney U test if
you're not sure how to interpret the
results just click on summary inverts
for the given data a man with new test
showed that the difference between
female and male with respect to the
dependent variable response time was not
statistically significant thus the null
hypothesis is not rejected
so we now calculate Demand with the U
test by hand for this we have plotted
the values in a table on one side we
have gender with female and male and on
the other side the values for reaction
time unfortunately the data is not
normally distributed so we cannot use a
t-test and we calculate the man with the
utest instead first we assign a rank to
each value we pick the smallest value
which is 33 which gets the rank 1 the
second smallest value is 34 which gets
the rank 2 the third smallest value is
35 which gets the rank 3. now we do the
same for all other values so now we have
all ranks assigned and we can just add
up all the ranks from women and all the
ranks from Men the rank sum is
abbreviated with t and we get T1 for
female with two plus four plus seven
plus nine plus ten plus five which is
37. now we do the same for male here we
get 11 plus 1 plus 3 plus 6 Plus 8 which
is
29. again our null hypothesis is that
both rank sums are equal now we want to
calculate the P value for this we have
once calculated the rank sum for the
female participants and we have the
number of cases of six therefore we have
six female subjects we can now calculate
the U1 that is the U for the female
participants using this formula here we
have n 1 and N2 that is the number of
cases of female and male minus the rank
sum of the female participants if we
insert our values we get a U1 of 14. we
now do exactly the same for the male
participants and we get a U2 of 16. so
now we have calculated U1 and U2 the U
for the man with new test is now given
by the smaller value of the two so in
our case we take the minimum of 14 and
16 this is of course 14. next we need to
calculate the expected value of U which
we get by N1 times N2 divided by 2. in
our case it is 6 times 5 divided by 2
and that is equal to 15. last but not
least we need the standard error of U
the standard error can be calculated
with this formula and in our case it is
equal to
5.4772 with all these values we can now
calculate that the set value results
with u minus mu U divided by the
standard error in our case we get 14
minus 15 divided by
5.4772 which is equal to minus
0.1825 so now we have the set value and
with the set value we can calculate the
p-value how ever it should be noted
depending on how large the sample is the
p-value for the man with new test is
calculated in different ways for up to
25 cases the exact values are used which
can be read from a table for large
samples the normal distribution of the U
value can be used as an approximation in
our example we would actually use the
exact values nevertheless we assume a
normal distribution for this we can
simply go to data Tab and calculate the
p-value for a given set value the
p-value of
0.855 is significantly greater than the
significance level of 0.05 and thus the
null hypothesis cannot be rejected based
on the sample how to calculate the man
with new test on tight ranks you can
learn in our tutorial on datatap.net you
find Link in the video description
thanks for watching and see you next
time